the white house coronavirus task force
wrapping up its briefing just minutes
ago behind me on Capitol Hill Senate
negotiators are trying to agree on a
bill that would give trillions of
dollars to Americans amid the growing
economic fallout of the current virus
outbreak with that we bring in
Democratic California Congressman friend
to the show member of the House Armed
Services Committee John Garamendi good
to see you sir what is your
understanding of the timeline here from
negotiations that are ongoing now to
when Americans who have been laid off
might see some money in their checking
account
probably that timeline the legislative
timeline will be this week sometime by
Susman next week midweek probably of how
quick those checks will go out to be
determined probably a few weeks after
that we hopefully it's going to be very
very fast however immediately available
to people that are laid off is the
unemployment insurance program and quite
possibly for small business business
interruption insurance assuming we
calculate this as not an act of God real
quick for you in California your whole
state is effectively under a shelter in
place shall tarat home what is effect is
this having on your constituents it
explained for people who are not in the
three states that are effectively locked
down what it's like well the example I'm
doing this from my home actually at my
ranch and we set up this video studio if
you will all across the state of
California people are doing the very
best to stay home do not be out and
about it has the enormous disruption on
business and obviously on the
individuals for my family and I think
for most other families I was headed
down to the studio as I was leaving the
rest my daughter waved me down and said
what do you think you're going so I'm
going to the studio she said no you're
not home and that's pretty good advice I
always gonna say 450 450 plus years
you've been listening to her it's worked
out pretty well so far we appreciate
your time congressman sorry we're gonna
have to cut it a little bit short but
we'll have you back either next week or
and healthier and better times and safe
travels
back to DC sir